[Music]
[Music]
hey guys the season 8 premiere just
ended it was great and I've already made
a breakdown on it so if you haven't
checked it out already make sure to do
so anyway in this video I'm bringing you
another breakdown this time on the
official season 8 episode to preview the
preview expectedly starts with the same
and the premiere ended with Jamie
Lannister as we found out in the end of
episode 1 an old friend Brent said he
was waiting for at night
venez by Sam what is he doing there turn
out to be Jaime Lannister Jaime
Lannister I Savannah fell he gets of his
horse and there he is bran stark a kid
he tried to kill many years ago many
wonder have all this meeting and for
Jaime
some say bran might punish him in some
way or even sentence Jaime to death well
the good news is none of that nonsense
is happening should be told it does look
like Jaime's on some kind of a trial
here for the crimes he's done against
both House Stark in House Targaryen the
trial looks almost exactly the same like
with Littlefinger Auto Lords present the
accused one in the middle and soldiers
running them all we have John Damien
sent sound here table with Tyrion under
left and brain on the right this is very
important so keep that in your mind
we'll touch on that in a bit
we also know that this worried face of
Brienne endow us that we got from
promotional photos are belonging to this
very scene brain's worried for half Dany
Targaryen the person he tried to kill
and brain stark also the person he tried
to kill will react it then he says to
Jaime when I was a child my brother
Viserys would tell me a bedtime story
about the man who killed her father
about all the things he would do to that
man doesn't look good for Jaime thus far
right when she says all the things he
will do to that man Jaime looks to his
left and in shock so it's understandable
at the first thought you get is javi
being sentenced or something like that
and it's okay because the teaser was
made to make us think that what follows
after Dain it says that is most likely
about her sharing the same intentions
with her brother until she finds out why
Jamie did it yes in case mr. Tyrion told
any while Jamie killed her father in the
ninth step is
the sixth season when discussing the
plan to deal with the slaver fleet that
was at the time besieging their city of
rain then he declared her plan to
destroy the Masters armies kill them all
and destroy their cities tyrion
disapproves and explains the
similarities between this plan and the
one her father had for King's Landing
when the Lannisters were at his door
Tyrion also said that the only reason
his brother Jaime killed her father was
because the Mad King wanted to burn city
to the ground along with its population
so then he already knows the truth
behind Jaime's so-called betrayal over
her father and will definitely not want
to punish him for that even she herself
admitted her father was an evil man back
in season 7 mm meeting chance now what
actually happens here is Jaime being
shocked at all the information from his
past brain is throwing at him here Jaime
looks to his left out right and who is
on the right of John Damian Sansa that's
right brain
Jaime's shocking face is not a result of
him being sentenced to death or anything
like that he's shocked about what Brent
says here remember to look since the gay
brain man he told her you look beautiful
that nineteen thousand seven well does
the same look Jaime gives the brain here
Brandon most likely provide more
backstory about Jaime and met king after
Danny says to Jamie that she understands
why he did what he did and it was the
right choice Jamie's like how do you
know all that not only that but both the
Jon Snow mundane invited all answers to
come and support the living in the worst
to come Jamie agreed an honor his pledge
meaning that no harm will they do to him
nor would he allow anyone else to do so
meaning that Arya most likely will not
kill Jaime as soon as she finds out
Jaime attempted to kill her brother
Tyrion Umbreon will be proud that
Jaime's honor his pledge
well then incense will be a bit
suspicious about his intentions upon
finding out that Cersei betrayed them
which they will find out from Jaime de
Vil ask invited he come to Winterfell
man his blood sister and lover is
obviously not going to help them and why
should they even trust him that's when
Jamie's lying from the official trailer
will come out he will reply with I
promise to fight for living and I intend
to keep that promise next we have
worried faces Subterra verse and Tyrion
as Danny walks by them and probably
enter someone's chambers varies Dany
going I have no idea it could be two
maester wolkan after she is
and that's when she finds out she's
pregnant also look at your hands face
here
he could be terrified by the thought of
it which would go in favor to a theory
about him being a traitor dead side of
it Cersei but he could also be scared
for life if she's been feeling very sick
we'll see from others is entities are
suing on the jury will soon after
entered that chamber to see Danny and
she does seem a bit upset perhaps she
does learn she's pregnant but mister
tells her she cannot possibly survive
another childbirth I could be wrong
though tell me what do you think about
it next we have a meeting between the
Lady of NFL and the dragon queen then it
says to her you never should have
trusted Cersei and sensor replies with
you never should have either since
implies to Danny trusting sir sent her
word she sent her army snort was not
smart however the good news is that some
sort of rivalry will probably stop in
Episode two as there's a promotional
photo from the same scene which we can
see Danny smiling it seems they might
get along after a few tense moments
let me savanna fell preparing for the
upcoming war with soldiers forming up
and the blacksmiths forging jealous
weapons in full juror gets hearts Bain
sends Valyrian steel sword this already
predicted what happened since Sam is not
a great fighter and probably will not be
on the first line
so his good friend Jorah would probably
be better to use it
Demi here Ari has already famous line
from the trailer again death it's got
many faces I look forward to seeing this
one just as a seeker shooting a bow this
is actually pretty interesting
viola noir is a great fighter with a
sword but what you might not know is
that Aria is also quite skilled at a bow
and arrow which we learn in one of her
very first scenes back in season 1
episode 1 maybe first see aria she's
being taught how to sew by septum or
Dane but finds the exercise tedious and
difficult in contrast to her sister
Sansa whose teaching is praised her
looks on enviously as a brother brain
John and Rob practice archery in the
courtyard with their father she grabs a
bow and a know his brain by out shooting
him Rob and John are impressed all bran
chases are as their family laughs at
their antics in season 7 watching over
the castle courtyard from the balcony
area reminisce about how their father
used to watch her and her brothers
trained in the very same spot
but early claiming that sense I would
not remember due to the fact that she
was usually inside the castle knitting
with her fellow ladies she didn't tell
sensor how on one particular day after
their brothers had finished training
with her Rajic she wandered into the
vacant courtyard and began practicing
her archery brands discarded bow as
their father watched from above
she was also being trained with a bow
for a short amount of time by angry a
skilled Archer hailing from the
Stormlands and a member of the
Brotherhood without banners all this
combined is clip of Aria once again with
a bow and arrow might hold some
significance to it will she use it to
kill by walkers from a distance perhaps
we know killing Bible curses of a huge
importance in winning this war because
if you kill one white Walker otherwise
he is raised from death also fall with
him this is the reason why Walker's
probably will not fight on the front
lines but Aria might use her second
weapon of choice to deal with that
problem next we have John and Danny in
the crypts of NFL since pretty much
everyone at this point knows who John
shal is as you could tell when are you
told to John not to forget our family
breath has basically told all his
siblings the truth it's time for Danny
to learn it as well and John definitely
feels like he's gotta tell her no one
else and this scene right here seems to
be John and Danny will discuss Ned Stark
why did he lie why he cut the line but
they will also probably talk about
John's father and then his brother ager
as well as about Leanna I don't expect
it to be a long scene but it will
definitely be a revelation scene then he
might even reveal to John she's pregnant
here if she really is or perhaps she
finds out later about her pregnancy in
this fact she's upset because the father
of their child is nephew many
possibilities here Thurman has also ride
the van FL and John has seen how long do
we have
Tommen replies before the Sun comes up
tomorrow they know the night King and
his army will be upon them soon and
they're preparing their stand even FL
many shots of the preparations for the
war chebyshev's are being tested and all
that the Dead will finally show up on
the horizon at the very end of episode 2
and the battle for Winterfell will take
place in the third episode that is
directed by great director Miguel
suppose Nick the one who directed battle
the bastards and win so van
here we have giant left Sam on the right
and probably theon greyjoy in the middle
remember that upon risking your Athene
was granted permission by his screen to
go for Winterfell and help the starters
offended so I think it's arrived and
this is him then we have a few shots
you've already seen in the official
trailer jerk amends Danny's forces
outside banner fell when I'm fell is not
huge enough to have all the armies
inside and since the track your horse
riders is the best to put them outside
so they could try to charge into and
possibly outflank the army of that they
will be accompanied with the Knights of
the Vale of course most of the unsullied
will be outside winner fellas that one
in the final shot we see Tyrion
Lannister on the walls of NFL as they
all wait for the knight King to attack
last time is so Tyrion on the walls
before major battle was on the walls of
King's Landing
just before he destroyed most of the
enemy fleet using wildfire
let's hope Tyrion has a trick in his
sleeve this time as well if you look
closely on this shot you can also notice
jealous all over the walls
this will come them hand even a dead
star climbing the walls what's also
interesting is that the entire preview
takes place of NFL anyways episode 2
will without a doubt be a great episode
and I cannot wait to see it stay tuned
for all the theory prediction videos
that are coming and I will definitely
make another video about episode 2 based
on absolutely everything we know and
have about it all the photos teaser
trailer and clips
many things that this preview did not
include and as always I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
make sure to subscribe to our Channel
and I hope to see in the next one peace